with us as we continue our election
coverage let's take a look right now at
the race for clark county school
trustees first off tonight in district a
lisa guzman
has a solid lead over her challenger
liberty levitt
taking a look now at district b vocal
president trump supporter this is katie
williams here walking away with this one
with 61
over jeff profit then evelyn garcia
morales this is a little closer between
her and tamika henry but she has a
comfortable lead right now nearly six
point lead and then in district e
between lisa brooks and alexis salt
looks like lisa
i should say lola brooks will be holding
on to her seat
this evening for the clark county school
district
no matter the outcome there will be at
least three new faces joining the board
8 news now reporter kristen drummond
is in our 80s newsroom she spoke with
the presumptive winners today
kristin well brian most are hesitant to
declare themselves the winner yet
they want to wait until all the votes
are counted to make it official
so when it is and if these results stay
the same it will once again be
all women on the board this will
definitely revamp the board as the three
current trustees in districts a b and c
term out
likely filling the seats are lisa guzman
katie williams and evelyn garcia morales
they're being elected during a very
uncertain time as the district navigates
the pandemic's economic as well as
academic fallout an issue the women seem
ready to address now
but approach differently when it comes
to students and staff
returning to the classroom i'm just
looking at the southern nevada health
district and if you look at those
numbers
you would say absolutely not by january
these schools need to be open no matter
what i
personally i'd like them to be open on
monday there is a lot of uncertainty
when it comes to reopening
schools right now especially without a
lot of information and a lot of data
the current board will vote on a hybrid
model next week
that's when students attend school a
couple days in person while continuing
distance education
the new board members will not be part
of that decision
they'll be sworn in this january and
then begin their duties
so trustee lola brooks attended a ccsd
board training meeting
and was unavailable for an interview
today but the district e
incumbent says she's happy with the
preliminary results and support during
the election
she also hopes to continue representing
district e and students as well as
families